Aww yeah, Harry Potter fan!
I'm back with another special lesson for you!
Today, we'll see Harry and his classmates
in Herbology class in their second year at Hogwarts.
Herbology is a real science
that studies herbs and medicinal plants.
In the Wizarding World, it studies
magical plants, as we'll see in today's scene.
This will be a great opportunity
for you to learn some specific vocabulary
in English about plants and gardening.
As you probably already know, this is
one of the great things about learning English
with different movies and series.
They give you all sorts of
real-life situations that can be useful
in gaining English fluency.
Are you ready for some fun?
Let's dive in!
Hey! Do you want to learn more about
how natives really speak in everyday situations,
while having fun with your favorite TV series?
Well, then our Fluent with Friends course
is perfect for you!
You will learn to understand how natives really speak
with lessons that follow along with the 48 episodes
of the first two seasons of Friends —
which various studies have shown
is the best series out there
for learning English.
You can try it for FREE right now
with our 3-Part Mini-course,
all you have to do is click up at the top,
or down in the description below
to Learn More and Sign Up,
and if you do, I hope you really enjoy it!
So, every single week, we make lessons
with movies like Harry Potter,
series like Friends, and interviews with
celebrities like Taylor Swift,
so that you can understand
fast-speaking natives
WITHOUT getting lost,
WITHOUT missing the jokes,
and WITHOUT subtitles.
For example, this subscriber says that
he's improving his English by watching
one of our lessons every single day.
And we can help you on your path to fluency too,
all you have to do is hit that Subscribe button
and the bell down below
so you don't miss a single one of our new lessons.
Have you seen all of our Harry Potter lessons yet?
Well, you can find all of our lessons
with the movies and interviews
by clicking up at the top or
down the description below
after you finish this video.
Awesome job today!
I hope you understood a lot better
that second time around.
And got a hundred percent on the quiz.
Remember, we're here to help you
on your path to fluency,
so be sure to check this other video
that I know you're going to love,
and Subscribe so you don't miss
any of our new lessons with Harry Potter,
and other movies and series
that you're going to really enjoy.
Now it's time to go beyond the classroom,
and LIVE your English!
Aww yeah!